Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Reinforcement learning is a class of learning
algorithms that chooses a set of actions in
an environment to maximize a score.
Typical use-cases of this include writing
an AI to master video games or avoiding obstacles
with a drone and many more cool applications.
What ties most of these ideas together is
that whenever we talk about reinforcement
learning, we typically mean teaching an agent
how to navigate in an environment.
A few years ago, a really fun online app surfaced
that used a genetic algorithm to evolve the
morphology of a simple 2D car with the goal
of having it roll as far away from a starting
point as possible.
It used a genetic algorithm that is quite
primitive compared to modern machine learning
techniques, and yet it still does well on
this, so how about tasking a proper reinforcement
learner to optimize the body of the agent?
What’s more, what if we would jointly learn
both the body and the navigation at the same
time?
Ok, so what does this mean in practice?
Let’s have a look at an example.
Here we have an ant that is supported by four
legs, each consisting of three parts that
are controlled by two motor joints.
With the classical problem formulation, we
can teach this ant to use these joints to
learn to walk, but in the new formulation,
not only the movement, but the body morphology
is also subject to change.
As a result, this ant learned that the body
can also be carried by longer, thinner legs
and adjusted itself accordingly.
As a plus, it also learned how to walk with
these new legs and this way, it was able to
outclass the original agent.
In this other example, the agent learns to
more efficiently navigate a flat terrain by
redesigning its legs that are now reminiscent
of small springs and uses them to skip its
way forward.
Of course, if we change the terrain, the design
of an effective agent also changes accordingly,
and the super interesting part here is that
it came up with an asymmetric design that
is able to climb stairs and travel uphill
efficiently.
Loving it!
We can also task this technique to minimize
the amount of building materials used to solve
a task, and subsequently, it builds an adorable
little agent with tiny legs that is still
able to efficiently traverse this flat terrain.
This principle can also be applied to the
more difficult version of this terrain, which
results in a lean, insect-like solution that
can still finish this level that uses about
75% less materials than the original solution.
And again, remember that not only the design,
but the movement is learned here at the same
time.
While we look at these really fun bloopers,
I’d like to let you know that we have an
opening at our Institute at the Vienna University
of Technology for one PostDoctoral researcher.
The link is available in the video description,
read it carefully to make sure you qualify,
and if you apply through the specified e-mail
address, make sure to mention Two Minute Papers
in your message.
This is an excellent opportunity to read and
write amazing papers, and work with some of
the sweetest people.
This is not standard practice in all countries
so I’ll note that you can check the salary
right in the call, it is a well-paid position
in my opinion, and you get to live in Vienna.
Also, your salary is paid not 12, but 14 times
a year.
That’s Austria for you — it doesn't get
any better than that.
Deadline is end of January.
Happy holidays to all of you!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you early January.